die heute-show zurück in alter Frische
und gewohnt negativ und sind sie auch so
wahnsinnig erleichtert meine Damen und
Herren die
ampelkoalitionskrise ist vorbei abgehakt
nach monatelangem akw-streit ist der
Weise Olaf von einem Berg herabgestiegen
und hat uns mit einem salomonischen
Urteil endlich Frieden geschenkt und der
Prophet sprach bis zum 15 April laufen
nicht zwei sondern drei Atomkraftwerke
weiter
gut da hätte man früher drauf kommen
können
aber immerhin ist die sinnlose Debatte
über ein Pillepalle Nebenthema endlich
vorbei beendet mit einem Machtwort bzw
ganz korrekt mit einem machtbrief von
Olaf Scholz der Kanzler zieht die
Richtlinienkompetenz plötzlich weht ein
ein Hauch von Führung durch die Ampel
der Kanzler hat ein Machtwort gesprochen
Bundeskanzler Scholz hat gestern einen
Machtwort gesprochen
und dann Machtwort gesprochen nun also
das Machtwort des Kanzlers basta der
Chef hat gesprochen
da raste ich mal aus
[Applaus]
Alter schwedene tickende Zeitbombe der
Mann ja ein Mann räumt auf übrigens der
letzte Kanzler der die
Richtlinienkompetenz ziehen musste war
Konrad Adenauer kein Witz will sagen
niemand ist aus dem albernen soft der
letzten Wochen unbeschadet rausgegangen
absolut niemand ja ist ja so es ist ja
so die FDP kriegt keine neuen Brennstäbe
zu Weihnachten und Habeck muss sich über
grüne Parteitagsbeschlüsse in wechselt
hier Roberts fröhliches Fazit zum AKW
Affentheater was glauben sie hat das für
einen Eindruck gemacht auf die deutschen
wahrscheinlich keinen guten und genützt
hat es auch nichts
hui da braucht aber einer dringend
Urlaub was
wo ist sie hin die jungenhafte
Unbeschwertheit na klar er muss jetzt
seiner Partei den Grünen erklären warum
man das AKW Emsland doch laufen lässt
aber andererseits hey die Grünen von
heute schlucken eh alles was man ihnen
hinhält ist es so Kinder was war das
gerade wieder für ein harmonischer
Parteitag da in Bonn oder eine Harmonie
bei den Grünen ja ja
wirklich alle Kompromisse alle
Formulierungen der Parteispitze wurden
am Ende brav abgenickt was ich mich
frage könnte man nicht mal was
versprechen was auch die grüne Basis
glücklich macht wir müssen die Menschen
durch den Winter bringen indem wir jetzt
die graspreise deckeln
zum Beispiel ja ja
natürlich ja
die graspreisbremse
Macht die ampelpolitik nicht besser aber
es ist ein legal
und jetzt mal unter uns immer ganz
ehrlich ob zwei oder drei AKWs bis Mitte
April hookers wenn überhaupt müsste man
den kompletten Ausstieg um zwei Jahre
oder so verschieben aber dann glühen dem
Trittin wahrscheinlich die Brennstäbe
durch insgesamt ist es aber schon
Wahnsinn was die Grünen von heute alles
mitmachen sie haben es gelesen das Dorf
lützerath wird jetzt doch weggebaggert
ja für eine für eine Handvoll Braunkohle
bzw hunderte Millionen Tonnen CO2 bis
neulich hat das grüne
Wirtschaftsministerium sogar ernsthaft
erwogen an der Nordseeküste schwimmende
ölkraftwerke einzusetzen also Schiffe
die Strom erzeugen indem sie Öl
verbrennen ist eine Riesensauerei Tanner
noch im Norden wo sie eh schon genug
Strom erzeugen ich sag mal wenn
überhaupt muss man so einen stinke kann
natürlich in Bayern parken am besten im
Tegernsee noch besser direkt vor dem
Haus von Uli Hoene und dann dann
verbrennt das Schiff natürlich nur das
Gute Öl aus Katar dass der Uli so gerne
mag das ist ja klar ja wer schön gewesen
hat sich jetzt wohl mit dem
akw-kompromiss erledigt ne aber dass die
Grünen überhaupt drüber nachgedacht
haben man nennt es wohl Realpolitik
nicht mal nicht mal die Waffenlieferung
an Saudi-Arabien hat auf dem grünen
Parteitag Ärger gemacht warum weil die
Annalena es gut erklärt hat die Ampel
liefert den Saudis ja im Rahmen einer
europäischen rüstungskooperation und
wenn wir die nicht hätten müssen wir ja
viel mehr Geld für die Bundeswehr
ausgeben weil ansonsten reichen die 100
Milliarden niemals aus und ich will
nicht dass wir noch mehr im sozialen
Bereich sparen und Lisa dann keine
Mittelmeer hat für die Kinder die sie
dringend brauchen so ja natürlich ja
natürlich nur wenn wir den Kampfjets
liefern also den kaschoggi zerschnetzeln
Arabien nur dann hat Familienministerin
Lisa Paus genug Geld für Kinder übrig ja
jeder einzelne Eurofighter hilft ihr ja
also
im Grunde muss man sich bei Prinz bin
Salman bedanken weil er uns als
Waffenkunde hilft unseren Kindern zu
helfen hier neue Kampagne
Hightech Waffen haben mein negatives
Image zu Unrecht denn warum bauen wir
Sie und liefern sie in alle Welt für die
Kinder nur für die Kinder ja dieser an
die Saudis vertickte Eurofighter
ermöglicht der Tagesstätte Pittiplatsch
in Cottbus ein neues Bällebad und jeder
Schuss Eurofighter Munition bedeutet
eine weitere Kelle Möhren
pastinakenstampf für die igelgruppe für
unsere Kleinen ist kein Deal zu dreckig
und in vielen jetsernen bald Bilder die
dankbare deutsche Kinder gemalt haben
wir bewaffnen Saudi-Arabien mit unserer
Aktion Rollern für plagen
wunderbar oder wunderbar
wir halten fest in der Ampel herrscht
also erstmal Frieden aber für wie lange
ein gewisser
Wolfgang Kubicki hat schon gesagt er
würde nächstes Frühjahr gerne noch mal
über Atomkraft sprechen um den nächsten
Zoff abzuwenden wurde jetzt sogar ein
ständiges
krisenpräventionsbüro eingerichtet dort
sitzt für die Grünen gisa-flake und
Lindners Referent Matthias Matschke für
die FDP Frau Flagge kehrt die Ampel denn
jetzt endlich zur Sacharbeit zurück ach
Gott das wäre so schön aber leider sind
wir grün ja die einzigen Erwachsenen in
dieser Regierung keine Ahnung was mit
der FDP gerade los ist aber ich kann
Ihnen als erfahrene Mutter nur sagen es
ist unerträglich
unerträglich Matthias Matthias hey wir
machen hier gerade eine Live-Schalte
kannst du vielleicht ein bisschen
mitmachen hallo
boah was
ich weiß er ist gerade in der ganz
schwierigen Phase hat vier
Landtagswahlen am Stück vergeigt und
fühlt sich vom Wähler gemobbt so als
Arschlöcher
Matthias nicht immer den Fehler bei
anderen suchen das haben wir bereits
mehrfach besprochen
wir haben einen riesen Fehler gemacht
wir hätten den nie das dritte
Atomkraftwerk geben dürfen goldene Regel
bockigen Kindern nicht nachgeben jetzt
will er natürlich immer mehr du hast
doch schon Necker westheimling und
dieser zwei ich will aber isa3 das
gibt's gar nicht damit bauen
dann willst du noch ein Eis haben ja
mein Gott dann hol dir ein Eis
dann ist er gleich wieder völlig
überdreht von dem vielen Zucker und hat
noch mehr blöde Ideen
du Gisa ja ich habe gerade eine Idee was
hältst du eigentlich davon wenn wir neue
Brennstäbe bestellen
weil dann hätten wir neue Brennstäbe und
wir tun was für die CO2 Bilanz wir
Liberalen sind die letzte Partei die in
Deutschland noch fürs Klima kämpft
ist das so das interessant du dann lass
uns doch ein Tempolimit einführen
120 auf Autobahn schwarz 2 Millionen
Tonnen CO2 im Jahr und wir es machen
können wir sofort machen hast du Bock
ja genau ich habe sowas von keine Lust
mehr wir grün da kann uns von morgens
bis abends ab in dieser Ampel Opfern
unsere besten Jahre und zurückkommt
nichts
außer frechen Kommentaren dieser
erklär mir und den Zuschauern doch mal
was nach dem 15 April wenn ihr Idioten
die drei AKWs abgeschaltet habt so viel
besser es in der deutschen
Energieversorgung und was wir nächsten
Winter ohne AKWs machen wenn Putin die
Norwegen Pipeline gesprengt hat das
das verstehst du eh nicht geh auf dein
Zimmer
ich hasse dich du bist überhaupt nicht
mein Koalitionspartner
wirst dann hätten dich niemals gekriegt
[Applaus]
nach Hause kommen das auch ein Arschloch
dieser Flak und Matthias Matschke vielen
Dank
ja
man kann nur beten
hoffentlich hört die Ampel jetzt
wirklich mal auf sich mit sich selber zu
beschäftigen denn die Krisen im Land
machen ja keine Pause ich sage nur
Inflationsrate im September zehn Prozent
gab es überhaupt noch nie im
wiedervereinigten Deutschland überall
schießen die Preise nur so durch die
Decke Stichwort sanifa Bong also gelesen
oder in den Worten von Deutschland
führendem fäkalblatt Pippi für einen
Euro
und will gar nicht wissen was groß
kostet egal ja man muss dazu sagen man
kann den Euro komplett für Einkäufe in
der Raststätte einlösen das heißt so
eine vierköpfige Familie kann sich dann
durchaus mal eine ganze Bifi leisten das
ist wirklich unfassbar diese
Preisexplosion 10% Inflationen die
Kaufkraft die Weg ist die bleibt auch
weg aber wie geht's weiter Christiane
von Berg sind sie genauso erschrocken
wie die meisten wahrscheinlich da
draußen ja ich denke man kann es an
meinem Gesicht sehen ich wirklich
schockiert
nein
ja der Klassiker sie hat wohl vergessen
dass ihr im Gesicht zu sagen
zehn Prozent Inflationsrate ja zehn und
Ökonom meinen da ist leider noch Luft
nach oben Meldung aus dieser Woche Gas
und strompreisdeckel kommen beide
frühestens im März wenn es wieder wärmer
wird ja solche Deckungen sind halt sehr
kompliziert weshalb ist ja klug gewesen
wäre rechtzeitig das mit den
Direktzahlungen an wirklich Betroffene
anzuschieben jetzt bleibt nur
Energiesparen und möglichst viel
Ökostrom nutzen seine Sucht nach
Ökostrom treibt mitunter Blüten wenn ein
Tag vorhersehbar eine gute Zeit war wo
man Strom gebrauchen konnte dann habe
ich mir meine Frühstückseier für die
ganze Woche vorgekocht
ja wenn dieser Mann morgen mit einer
Tupperdose zu ihnen zuckerteil steigt
fliehen sie so lange noch Zeit ist meine
Damen und ja okay immerhin will die
Ampel unsere Gasrechnung für Dezember
übernehmen da gibt es ausnahmsweise mal
nichts zu meckern
wobei
die Zahlung basiert auf der September
Abrechnung und sehr viele Deutsche haben
ausgerechnet im Oktober eine fette
Erhöhung bekommen sodass sie am Ende
eben nicht alles ist egal ist egal kein
Wunder dass in deutschen Medien jetzt
ständig über do it yourself Heizungen
berichtet wird wie den Bekloppten
teelichtofen ideal für Leute die immer
schon Ihre Vorhänge abfackeln wollten ja
es wäre oder irre wenn man das früher
geahnt hätte fast alles mit Teelichtern
geht wir fahren so blöd haben jahrelang
teure Heizung installiert dabei lag die
Lösung der Energiekrise die ganze Zeit
bei Ikea an der Kasse ich behaupte mit
nur fünf Millionen Teelichtern kannst du
lockern Hochofen betreiben
oder hier einfach eine Solarzelle aufs
E-Auto packen Teelicht davor und schon
lädt der Tesla während der Fahrt oder
und jetzt wird es total verrückt Freunde
ein Teelicht das Tee warm hält sie
merken das Potenzial ist quasi endlos
teelichtofen wir haben definitiv auch
eine geistige Energiekrise immerhin bei
Strom und Gas hilft der Staat bei
Lebensmitteln nicht gar nicht klar auch
da sind die Erzeugerpreise gestiegen
aber manche Konzerne sind halt gieriger
als andere Fachleute sprechen von gear
flations möglicherweise bald ganz
verschwunden aus vielen Supermärkten der
US-Konzern Mars will die Preise erhöhen
Rewe und Edeka akzeptieren das nicht die
Forderungen seien nicht mit höheren
Rohstoff oder Energiepreisen zu
begründen was
aber wann ist denn dann wieder Miracoli
Tag
nie mehr wie schade ja die gute mit
Wasser angerührte tomatenschlotze naja
der Mars Konzern beliefert Rewe und
Edeka nicht mehr gar nicht mehr Hammer
oder und leider kein Einzelfall leider
kein Einzelfall auch andere Konzerne
Procter und Gamble Kellogs Coca-Cola
planen drastische Preiserhöhung
natürlich ist Gier also das Streben nach
gewinnen die Essenz des Kapitalismus und
Rewe und Edeka sind doch nicht per se
die guten wenn man bedenkt welche
dumping Preise die regelmäßig den
Landwirten aufdrücken gibt es denn zum
Thema Lebensmittel noch Ideen aus der
Politik ich könnte mir gut vorstellen
dass wir die Mehrwertsteuer
beispielsweise Obst Gemüse Hülsenfrüchte
vom reduzierten Mehrwertsteuersatz auf
Null setzen tja der Cem do der alte
Bauer Ranger ne ja
hat wohl einer Bock auf den nächsten
Veggie day Shitstorm wie ja es ist aber
eigentlich wenn man darüber nachdenkt
gar nicht so ein blöder Vorschlag
gesundes Essen billiger machen klar wenn
die Deutschen sich plötzlich alle
gesünder ernähren dann hätte das
natürlich auch unangenehme
Nebenwirkungen zum Beispiel für die
Hersteller von Leggings und stretchosen
die werden ratzfatz Pleite Millionen
ehemals übergewichtige deutsche Männer
und zum ersten Mal ihren eigenen Penis
sehen
Enttäuschung vorprogrammiert so was
haben wir wir haben Inflation
gierflation und dann auch noch
schwingflation
schwingflation ist der gemeinste Trick
der Lebensmittelbranche also selbe
Packung aber geschrumpfter geschrinkter
Inhalt Gernot Hassknecht ist einmal mehr
empört Vorsicht Falle Nepper Schlepper
Schrumpf bescheißer mit gernotasknecht
nichts gegen beschissfreunde aber
ehrlich muss er sein wenn der maßkonzern
den Hals nicht voll kriegt damit kann
ich leben weiß eh nicht wer das
freiwillig frisst Bauschaum mit
Schokolade drum boah was mich aufregt
ist verdeckter Beschiss unglaublich was
die sich da heute für Tricks einfallen
lassen manches ist für den Laien gar
nicht zu erkennen Gerolsteiner schießt
den Vogel ab aus 12 Flaschen
zitrusbrause werden sechs bei gleichem
Preis ja da muss man schon genau
hingucken um 6 von 12 zu unterscheiden
hier rächt sich unser kaputtes
Schulsystem der deutsche rechnet nicht
gern
studienbeweisen dass der Verbraucher auf
Preiserhöhungen viel sensibler reagiert
als auf weniger Inhalt Beispiel 1
Pringles Original in der alten Packung
Links waren noch 200 Gramm Chips
enthalten in der neuen sind es nur noch
185 Gramm das entspricht auf unserer
Waage 8 Chips die nun weniger drin sind
oh jetzt wird's persönlich mein
täglicher Bedarf sind drei Stangen
bringens das heißt ich werde jeden Tag
um 24 Tipps beschissen das sind in der
Woche
168 und im Jahr
8.736 wo sind meine
8.736 Pringles ihr Schweine und Holz tut
wie immer nichts
ändert endlich die Verpackungsordnung
wer den Inhalt schrumpft muss auch die
Verpackung schrumpfen den kleinen
Unterschied sieht man erst auf den
zweiten Blick tatsächlich sind die
Blätter auf den Rollen in der
Großpackung etwas kleiner
was soll denn das
Briefmarken als Klopapier raus ernsthaft
teurer machen von mir aus aber
schrumpfen ist eine absolute
Unverschämtheit bitte
manche machen beides das
Vorgängerprodukt hatte 80 Gramm Inhalt
jetzt sind es 60 Gramm gleichzeitig ist
der Preis bei einem Händler laut
Verbraucherzentrale von 75 auf 95 Cent
gestiegen macht eine Preiserhöhung von
sagenhaften 69%
ernähren sich von Katzenfutter passt
doch wenigstens die Namen an dann heißt
nimm zwei Balken im eins aus 47 11 wird
46 10 und auch Dickmanns
magersuchtmanns doch gut wenn das jetzt
alle machen und die Politik guckt nur zu
dann machen wir das eben auch die
Rundfunkgebühr bleibt bei günstigen
18,36 Euro aber wir kürzen beim Inhalt
also außer beim Traumschiff da gibt es
ja keinen
und meine Nummern bei der heute-show
enden auch nicht mehr mit einem Gag
sondern mitten im Satz vorsicht vor
Schlepper Schwimmbad
[Applaus]
so Aufnahme
hallo dies ist die automatische endcard
von Oliver Welke und der heute-show
leider ist das Video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den Kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres Video
anschauen vielen Dank so müsste jetzt
für immer reichen